podcast man special guests in here about
to do his thing my guy
op man on point like op in the building
yes yes you already know Canarsie is
here Brooklyn let's find this what do
you got first of all uh just shout out
what you got going on before we have you
do your thing I uh April 7th My
Brother's Keeper my official album tape
whatever y'all want to call it got
features from Bobby rowdy uh Rod switch
Dusty Jim Jones the squad yeah the squad
uh and TJ Porter I got something for the
ladies okay you just told me off the air
you were like I don't want to be known
as a drill rapper no okay so this
project you feel like you're gonna be
like versatile versatile yeah I just do
what feels right I don't know and I feel
like I wrapped out a lot of Cali beats I
could stand with any Cali rapper put me
in
the best rappers come from New York in
my opinion oh see look see I like it
historically hey but look man we're
gonna get right to it man you already
know go follow my guy on point like op
Canarsie in the building let's go
let's get it it's so important like op
April 7th My Brother's Keeper
[Music]
everything I do I'm having fun being me
why would I want to be you
man I know you could shine like me
ground like me anything is possible
look
[Music]
look no you see the drip baby check the
detail Chopper sing like New Edition
never get nervous when a [__] C12
knowing [__] State striped gotta stay
safe ain't talking seat belt no [__]
that's still but they won't kill call
his ass he's out got it on my own never
need a handout got it off my free will
catch a hop out of bounds no second
thoughts no that's a free kill never
question ain't y'all cause if I shoot
already know he will my brother's the
same no matter the fame know we all
equal Stripes have been off the car no
it's a big body running on diesel never
stop at red lights no you heard future
moving like it's legal how to grind for
31 days straight now I'm in beast mode
and don't say you're a real [__] if you
ain't feed your people tell you what you
gotta hear not what you want won't
mislead you same [__] hating in your
comments they really just want to be you
trying to make millions off of music
like Jay-Z or the Beatles everything
high class my life a movie no there's a
preview
[Music]
and I want y'all to let me know if I'm a
drill rapper all right listen Man album
comes out April 7th April 7th April 7th
go run that [__] up man shout out to the
floss baby hey I know you just watched
the new freestyle guess what we're
dropping them every week sometimes more
than once a week Jesus we've been
dropping a lot lately uh shout out to
LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week